61 both cars
out what's going on Sir these guys are
mouthing off to me W let me do my order
okay and the issue hand is I I had an
order with them and I was taking the
order with them okay and then what
happened from there well they they want
to they wouldn't let me trade out
anything so why aren't you guys in here
talking to these guys I haven't done
anything wrong you've been yelling and
causing a dist they I got him on video
yelling and screaming at me okay that's
perfectly fine yeah they they initiated
to them to me the guy came out called me
twice okay so don't sit there and say I
started it these guys came out to me why
would they come out to you because they
were I I placed an order okay how's it
going not bad how are you I'm a little
pissed off right now I sure see that
yeah I took an order I paid for my stuff
but these guys are all coming out here
yelling and screaming calling me names I
have them on video and they're telling
me that I'm mad and that I'm calling
them names they came out to me
first okay was your order wrong or
something or what they don't they don't
have any carbonation in here so I I I
obvious get number two it's got a three
soft tacos and a freeze I upgrade freeze
they don't have it so the issue at hand
is that they want to sit there and tell
me that well it's it's a up it's uh
they're going to give me something
different like tea I don't want tea or
water I can get water at
home
okay so then they had a verbal argument
with them or the guy started yelling and
screaming at me from behind this guy
over here starts be on screaming at me I
got it on video I got them telling me I
mean the whole thing about it is that
the drink is actually cheaper than the
that there or
$255 I just give me Bean burrit L though
okay Lou means
trade okay
um there was a comment about someone
spitting on somebody I didn't spit on
him but I have a spee impediment and
when I speak loud it comes out okay so
it's not an issue but the guy wants to
be an issue so you didn't intentionally
hog a lugie or spit in somebody's face I
don't I don't even know how to do that
okay do you have your ID or anything on
you real quick why don't you get your ID
though well that's what I'm going to
have yeah I'm good here go and see
what's going on
there you have your recorder on oh of
course great this mine's about to run
out okay is this a good address for you
as well I Liv here 20 years okay you
District Tre what's that are you in
District three District three are you in
District dist 3 I just asked a question
I'm this is district 6 I'm sorry I
thought it was District 3 because I
spoke to Lieutenant is it D'Angelo or Jo
D'Angelo okay he knows me
okay go for thank you okay we'll give
you that back what's a good uh phone
number for
you want see my receipt take a picture
of
that
my mistake you want to see my receipt
you take a picture of my driver's
license why don't we take a picture of
that okay what well it shows you that
I'm a customer I'm not here
involuntarily they told me to come in
okay so they told you to come inside yep
they said come on in okay all right I'll
SC that
back okay so just a verbal argument
between you guys I didn't touch the guy
I've been law enforcement before a long
time ago okay so I know that but these
guys mouth and off and I have way and
walked right up to is back off and he
wants to talk toy this guy here come up
after to the thing twice calls me names
so I have people from the front and back
okay so you're in the Drive-Thru having
an argument with the guy at the
drive-thru thing yeah but they were
yelling and screaming at me okay and
then the guys starts I'm talking to the
people at Taco Bell and then they come
up and they're on schem to me you get
the hell out of here just go just go and
I want my order okay I ordered it okay
and then they told you to pull up front
of here and then that's when you were
going in there they the manager and they
says come on in come on in come inside
the lobby oh the manager when you were
parked here told you to go inside I was
leaving and then the guy comes out
starts calling me names okay and stuff
like that and I just he you know but the
manager just come on inside the place
okay but is that so so you're leaving
the manager comes out asking no no the
manager was in the in the thing the dve
oh okay telling you to come inside come
inside okay uh looks like you're kind of
blocking the drivethru a little bit
would you mind just pulling forward just
so by the light I'm a big truck okay
that's
fine has have you been drinking at all
today or anything I haven't had a drink
in 25 years okay that's I don't drink I
don't do spot smoke pot or nothing why
is that a question that you do that I
saw you kind of stumble a little bit so
I have spee imped I've already said this
twice spe I'm not I just have a
speech imped I don't drink I haven't had
a drink in 25 years I've never had a DUI
or been in prison that's fine I'm not
saying you you just sit there and said I
have this thing like I've been drinking
why I just saw you just come up the
curve I just want to make sure you're I
got boots on it's icy out I just want to
make sure you're no you're being you're
being difficult I am not you are you if
you feel comfortable to go in your car
meet me over there we'll continue time
how much I've had to drink I said have
you had anything to drink I drink gorad
that's all I do all right gorad that's
fine I no pot no drinks no marijuana no
nothing okay I just didn't want an issue
to happen smoke cigarettes and these
people flick cigarettes outside okay you
do you see me spitting this now I I do I
get it I'm not holding anything against
you I just want to make sure you're
capable of operating a more vehicle that
is it why don't you ask them if they're
having dreams I'm just curious I'm
talking with you my my deputies in there
so so because I'm walking on rocks and
uh my phone stopped working here because
I'm stop walking rocks in ice and
snowing boots I'm drunk I didn't say you
were well it seems like you asked me if
I how I've had to drink tonight or today
I asked you if you've drinken anything
today what does that have to be I mean
I'm not a du why I haven't done anything
wrong I'm not saying you did it was a
question
that's that's the whole reason that's
the whole reason why I'm out here not
even asking them I have you ask her I
have my partner in there talking about
okay so fair have you had anything Dr
okay well it looks like they're able to
get around so don't worry about moving
your
vehicle I will move it up to the front
here meet pal a new maximum strength
self-defense product with a patented
modular design revolutionizing the
self-defense industry whether you're
caring the unit on your keys snapping it
on your backpack or your keychain or
carrying the pepper spray in your pocket
Palm is the perfect everyday carry
accessory Palm's patented fliptop safety
prevents any accidental misfire and its
maximum strength formula provides you
with the necessary range and capacity to
bring peace of mind to you and your
loved ones learn more at Palm peppers
spray.com and use code body cam1 for 10%
off have done with today I want to be
left alone but when people start coming
up and you on the screen and me I'm I
don't have right to talk back to them
well I mean is it is it okay it's the
one-sided world no it's not one-sided no
I'm just wondering what what would you
like us to do today so if if we find
that there's charges to be able to be
able to press on him or the employees
there would you like us to pursue any
type of charges I want I mean I just
want my my I come here but the lady says
I do this all the time I've never done
this before you know the L comes out
videotapes me but I I have it on video
that I asked her I says just give me a
bean burrito and L of it sure do you
know what I mean I'm not trying to be
disrespectful instead of instead of
there you go instead of educational
thing and she's like it's
$2.55 for the drink the bean burrito is
$189 okay so I says I'll take the bean
burrito sure but she's like no I can't
do that you can either have a a Brisk
iced tea you can have a cup of water I'm
like no I get a mango freeze all the
time I have so many of these receipts
that are all Taco Bell I get the same
thing I don't have any weapons no I was
just I was just looking at where you're
your gra you seem like a nice guy but
the issue hand is that I've got friends
or are cops I used to be a cop a long
long time ago I don't go around
professing I'm a cop but the issue in is
that people get a little defensive by
hey were you reaching for things so I
don't have any weapons in my vehicle I'm
sorry again I just spit by accident no
you're you're fine I understand but the
issue here is that I'm just getting my
Taco Bell if they don't have something
here and I started recording her when
she she said nope you can get water I'm
like I was like water I can get water at
home okay you know I I come here to get
the the the fre are you Rao County by
the way yes rapo County that's why I
missed it cuz I just now saw a sheriff
oh yeah R County why are we why are you
Sheriff out here and we in city of
Aurora in instead of Aurora yeah uh it's
just the house city of centennials
broken up
are we in centenal yeah yeah I didn't
know this was Centennial I mean I come
right up to yeah so Aurora starts um
across the street so Smokey Hill here 20
years never knew that oh okay no it's
all good so all that side on uh from
Smokey is Aurora or yeah is Aurora and
then we have set this off you got your
video on oh yeah yeah got it and then we
start again um we have a lot of
unincorporated areas and stuff that we
how we T you so I got I got the title on
registration that I just bought the
truck for my dad so he died two years
ago okay I got it um paid my mom for it
I have the bill of sale for it I don't
really drive this truck but the hway is
telling me I got to move some Vehicles
sure no and that that kind of makes
sense cuz when dispatched aired it out
it registered to your dad and yeah
men yeah
absolutely
I'm voluntarily showing you this oh I I
appreciate
it was this a suicide note or no okay
I'm not committing suicide no no no no I
meant by not not for you I just that's
my mom she's the okay executive of the
state saying that over she sold me the
St I offered she sold it to it for
dollar I said no my brothers and sisters
would be mad so I gave her $10,000 cash
that $5,000 5,000 okay well that's
that's perfectly fine okay all right um
so my partner's in there he's finishing
up with them um it sounds like it was
just a verbal argument why can't I I
mean why do other people these young
kids I'm not trying to be disrespectful
to you but they jump out and start
yelling and screaming calling me names
I'm twice their sides right you know I'm
not trying to be a bully I'm talking to
them right and then they come out say
hey you got to move your vehicle I'm
like no I got my issues with them and
either they can back up and I mean I was
trying to back up but they wouldn't let
me back up so it's either go forward and
the lady says well you can come in I'm
like well right I I want my thing right
and that's when you came in well I mean
I only came in when the guy came out so
young at me big old guy baseball cap was
he cussing at you or anything cussing me
I got him on video what was he saying
said you're a said that
to me twice and he I mean he came
outside to have a confrontation with me
while I'm in the drive I'm I'm spinning
again um and the fact is that that when
I was is leaving he goes goodbye
like that so he did it the second time
through the through the drivethru window
he came out no no he oh he actually came
out okay and he's standing in front of
me and I'm you know coming out so then I
stopped and I said well why are you
being like that and then the other
guys's man but the issue at hand is is I
mean we're wasting more time you're
wasting time you guys can be do doing a
million other things sure this is trivia
but you have other people feel like that
they have to yell at at me right you
know I mean I'm not interrupting them
I'm not in their life okay sure right it
just seems like you just wanted
something to be switched out and then
somebody got mad about it and then I did
I I have the lady cleared on the things
she said but they say I do this all the
time I've never done this before I do
have cuz you live all the way down off
of rapo and who you from your address up
here I'm at Quincy and Chambers Quin oh
okay my mistake you just go right down
here uh to uh Smokey Hill and just take
a ride on Chambers right that
right at the top of the street right
okay gotcha I must have misunderstood
the address
that oh no you're you're good is the
okay I got
you you know it's just I don't know who
the the developer was
but okay all right um let me get my
partner quick call and just see what he
got um what's your first name my name is
bla bla you seem like a good guy I'm
sorry I came off across but I'm just
pissed off no I get it I understand
people are heated you know when they
first you know when I when we show up
you know so i' like to have well the guy
saying I'm going to take off with I'm
not going to take I ain't got no
warrants out for me right you know I
mean I I I I don't drink I don't I mean
not my my two vices in life is coffee
donuts and Gator drink frozen Gator okay
yeah no that's that's perfectly fine so
I'm I'm not sure what they want to do
over there um you think I Spit on well
they said that somebody spit on somebody
spit I mean I just have a speech Impe
and my issue is that when I get more
vocal wise more verbal it just comes out
right but it's not an intentional act
it's just me talking right you know and
and that's and that's what I get from
having this conversation with you so I I
can already articulate that I don't
believe that you intentionally spit on
them like straight up hog
I don't know how to do that I've seen
people do it all the time I don't do
that I never done that sure Here Comes
Your Boss no that's perfectly fine
partment so let me just talk to him real
quick and he a big guy by the way yeah
we we get we go way back work from the
are you a football player I was who' you
play for what's that who'd you play for
I didn't get College I wasn't that good
you're big boy I wouldn't mess with
you you talk to me I'm not going to it's
a
deterr I mean if you I always joke I'm a
big guy but I'm 290 big tall you know
there guys that are 290 your size I'm
like you got to be every B of 200 lb
some man yeah but I'm just saying that I
I would
still if I I ever got in a fight and I
don't I lose in the fight we both lose
stupid so do you mind if I just talk to
him real quick over here no you're good
anything I got nothing criminal
um might trespass him but their manager
not here and they don't have any letters
ready so I told him we would verbally do
it and if he comes back try to have the
letters ready so they can formally do it
okay and then that's it all right Pur
yeah I don't have any initi from him um
sp there talking with him for a little
bit I'm not SP anything I just believe
it's just a speech impediment and that's
probably why they think he was wrong all
um it was just a veral argument there
was just Sim wanting to exchange a bean
burrito for a drink that they didn't
have right um
that's okay outside too
no okay no specific that that's made he
told one dude to step outside that's a
little too
bag okay yeah so that's that's literally
yeah he said the manager told him to
pull around and come inside so then
that's when he pulled out and then one
of the guys yelled through the
drive-thru ceer and then he stopped
right there and then he came out and
told him hey hi get out of here and then
that's when he went in there cuz the
manager told him to come inside right
which he was pulling around to do that
and just seems like a whole huge ver
that so yeah I'm just gonna dispill this
out as some call notes what's his first
name um I got his ID here I'm just going
to let him know that they don't longer
one them on the on the property okay um
Bruce so we'll just kind of go from
there
[Music]
cool
me
communicate I'm just the middle man at
this point don't get mad at me the
management doesn't want you around the
car that is
your the they don't
[Music]
want what's
that that's not
important how was that
important it's from now on I'm not
saying that I'm charging you a trespass
or anything after come in I'm saying
from now on they don't want you doing
business with their store inside their
store okay and that is your right I'm
just passing that on to you okay so next
time you come out here you know they
recognize you or whatever like that
they're going to for trespass never law
I'm not I'm not saying you get that's
why there's nothing
here okay do you have any questions for
me
Bruce and I thought so too and now
you're getting next time you come out
is how is that a threat I don't mean to
do that all you have to say is good if I
come out do you have any
questions so here's my business card and
on the back is the incident number
pertaining to this call so but the fact
that he sat there and said next time you
come out here I don't need to hear that
that's absolutely a threat I don't need
to hear it it's absolutely a thre I'm
not going to sit in and argue with you
it is do you have any other questions it
is yeah I want to know the names of the
people in here okay why well you gave
him my name no I didn't you didn't no I
didn't even know your name until I
walked out here and my partner told it
to me the the people inside I had no
idea who you were until I walked out
here and my partner told me that your
first name was Bruce I have no idea what
your last name is I have no idea what
your date of birth is nor do I care at
this point we didn't we didn't give any
of your information to them and they we
didn't give any of their inform what was
the pr that happened other than that man
everybody's story is matching up that
you wanted an exchange of a burrito for
a drink uh
somebody yeah for drink right the cuz
the drink wasn't available and you
wanted the burrito instead you know
upgraded hey we what we can do in L that
they didn't she didn't understand that
so that's why I asked you if you knew
what the Lord not being disrespectful
knew that you proce and understand that
but the fact of the matter is that these
other you guys come out yelling a scream
calling me a names I mean I'm right I'm
you imagine standing there and having
some yell and scream you f I'm sure you
get back in their face like you're in my
face now so the intense well and
according to them it was you who started
you were getting people's faces
insulting it's at this point he you I
get it and they have video of it too did
of them so here's the thing though at no
point did anything criminal happen so it
doesn't matter what words work then why
is your investigation here because we
were called here if we're called for an
inent we're going to investigate it and
at the end of the day we determin that
there's nothing criminal anytime
somebody calls 911 that's I've never
called that's the number that's
generated for it there's no case number
there's no nothing so I'm going to put
call notes in that I talk to you you can
say he would hot-headed yell and
screaming and all that stuff no I'm just
going to say it was just a verbal
argument between a customer and
employees nothing criminal well no but
what about the people that were that
were they were as well I me there's like
eight people okay so that's not just
Bruce and and the employees right no I'm
saying all the employees that were in
there having a verbal argument with you
what about the other people that in the
LA you didn't talk to them I talked to
them okay so there's not an issue is
that they're yelling and screaming at me
I mean you're just putting down me Bruce
is yell I'm not doing anything at this
point the management of that Taco Bell
just does not want you around they
didn't mention anything about the other
two that's not my choice here's y'all's
thing y'all's report goes after a bunch
of people and they well there's report
going to be made there's no report you
said that there between me and the
employees a verbal alation yeah saying
why not these men these people that were
in the lobby the on screen that came out
and call me n why are they not in so
yeah they were young were they citizens
in yeah I talked to them I identified
them I know who they are I have their
contact
info all right
okay you shake hands or I I do knuckles
so all right all right thank you for
your time Bruce sorry about this thank
you for taking the time with us all
these you never knew with this okay try
to try to have a good rest of your day
sir I had a great day okay I'm soorry
but these guys are they're going to get
to was I guarantee you no that's that's
totally fine it's your practive have a
good day
sir
um apparently it's all locked
[Music]
up
how's it going it good yeah how many
employees do you guys have here right
now four four okay um can I an in it
yeah so what's happening is um you guys
are actually being shut down right now
uh we have our supervisors on the way
out and our investigations team as well
so I need all your employees to come out
to the front here and just have a seat
uh we're going to be getting a hold of
the manager for the company
um and we'll explain a little bit more
about what's going on um as soon as my
supervisors get here but again for right
now every single employee here is being
detained and nobody is free to
go okay detention um for a while um so
it's going to be for um an investigation
we have going on right now um it's going
to relate to the poisoning situation
poisoning yes but right now so and I'm
going to let somebody else elaborate on
that uh but right now I need all of the
employees to just go ahead and shut
everything down and come out to the
front here okay okay so we need to call
our GM uh yes I think we have somebody
that's working on that right now but
you're more than welcome to give them a
call um and see if they can come out
here because we have no idea what's
happening yeah yeah the GM doesn't get
out here we're trying to have somebody
get in contact with them but if you have
a faster way to get a hold of the GM
that would be
fantastic
all right you guys so again I see
everybody shut everything down and come
out to the front Okay and again nobody
nobody can leave all
right so that's a g for the stor you
would like to speak the get so C no idea
what's happening okay who is that you on
the phone with my general manager from
this store okay and that person's on the
way here no they're not here they not on
the way here
okay who I stay right he is at State
okay yeah gotcha um but I thought he
would know what's happening so if he
doesn't know yeah no he he's probably
not going to be aware of what's
happening cuz this this is all just kind
of starting right now um we are like I
said our our investigations team is
coming out so they're going to contact
the general manager and everything
they're going to completely explain
what's going on
therey
uh you want to go a log real
quick uh you guys all have IDs with
you's your off what's that what's your
name gon yes Deputy gon G yes
sir uh we
we
um I can't let you take the food uh
there's an issue you're going to have
have to call them and get a refund on it
I apologize for that but you may not
want the food is the other issue
[Music]
okay yeah sorry you guys have
to go through all this I know this is
kind of abnormal this is it this is
pretty abnormal for us too um so it's to
you know folks a lot higher up making
this call based on what we have going on
um
so you
know we're going to have some folks come
in I think they're going to want to talk
to you guys um I'm not 100% sure how
this is going to operate
um we'll just kind of play it by ear
like I said this is kind of an abnormal
thing for us as well so uh if you guys
have any questions we'll answer them as
best as we
can um but we're we're only going to
have so many answers for you right now
okay uh were there any other employees
that left recently oh recent uh when was
the last employee that
left at 7 yeah uh how many people left
at 7 it was us and it was one other girl
there's one other girl yeah okay and
then before her it
was at 5 o'
to 5:00 two people left at 5:00 two
people left and then the one girl left
at
okay I at least you guys are on the
clock still you know what a wait to be
on the
clock you're you're at least getting
paid to do
this
how's it going Serge
hello hi hi
hi doing all right how about you guys
not doing all right at all I hear you I
hear the bewilderment here now just walk
through so far just make sure that's
everybody here four employees one
employee left at 7 two employees left at
5 okay who was uh who left at seven uh
female
yeah what's her
name what's uh the gal that left at
seven what's her first
name you know her last name by chance no
she explain to him you know what's going
on they kept asking I told him there was
a you know poisoning issue is the reason
we're here told them everybody else
going have to explain whatever when they
get here
um she has
a before leave okay um other than
that
good go for
cop I got confirm for her um oh now we
do they want us
to search anything or we just waiting
for them I have no idea what the hell is
happening um let's check trash cans that
kind of stuff like the dumpster drop
back cuz they if they broke open a rat
trap or something like that okay um
anything I can go back there and look I
just came here just to see what you guys
needed I didn't know how many people you
I can go that I take care of that but
that's what we're looking for did you
get the pictures no of what it looks
like what we're looking for for uh no I
did not
you but then also three do we know a
time
frame um at 1946 is when we got notified
that okay uh the guy was at the hospital
that had been poison at this off he
didn't say when um I don't witsman has
the receipt I'm guessing that will tell
us exactly when but I just sent you a
picture weing those three employees that
left
is uh balls yeah the green balls and
then whatever that or yeah the green
balls cuz if you flip through to the
next one they're just on top that one's
like hidden they're just oh wow those
are rat poison balls and then that is
like some sort of cleaning agent or
something I don't know no yeah okay
so that's a lot more legit than I
thought it was yeah okay so he takes one
bite immediately starts vomiting burning
throat all that other stuff he gave
consent they're going to go CSI is going
to leave the hospital after collecting
the food and the poison they're going to
go to his house collect all the vomit
samples with the poison in it okay I'm
just going to let them know what's going
on real quick and then we'll start
checking around
y
can Stu foot in there
so we're going to start checking around
exterior trash cans trash cans inside
this is what we're looking for so it was
actual rat poison was put in the food so
that's these green balls right here so
we're looking for anything like that
traps that may have been broken open um
there's more of it and then there's also
some kind of cleaning agent was put in
there so what happened was the guy take
took one bite with this food immediately
started burning vomiting um so they went
to the hospital they confirmed it is in
fact poison poison hospitals yeah so
right now they're treating us as they
attempted homicide
investigation um so just kind
of you know trash cans outside trash
cans um any place inside you know
underneath stuff any like traps that may
have been broken open anything like that
that's what we're looking for okay so
I'm going to check the outside trash
cans here I'll go through that
investigation wants us to check the
trash cans yeah we're Cy was want us to
do that right now um so if you guys want
to check inside I can check the outside
stuff are we just going around here or
are we going in the back yet um ask like
if uh wait
for potential paper let me uh let me
just ask if he wants
to